it's crazy because it's I I you know I I
feel like Russ was the OG guy who was
like telling the truth to rappers but
they were like Russ is a dick right I
feel like your message has been a lot
more palatable right you've inspired I'm
sure people you don't even know you've
inspired at this point man [__] be crazy
like big artist I'm talking about
superstars I'm cuz your content has been
digested labels use my blueprint like if
there's there's there's not too many
offices who don't know who I am and what
I'm doing and telling their and they all
hate on you when I bring listen can I be
honest with you right please all of
these industry guys cuz I bring your
name up all the [__] time they all
are hating on you right I'm telling you
they all say the same yeah but but he
ain't got like a like a hit like what's
where's the music and I'm like what like
this happens this I promise you
that a version of that conversation's
happened at least 20 times you what's
crazy too is like um and I'm talking
about people in city city I have T man I
got I know I got tons of songs and like
the the difference is the amount of
money that you're able to put behind a
record like [__] don't understand
[__] be on on label deals and then
contracts and I got a million followers
and made millions of dollars and they
haven't but [__] are talking about oh
you ain't got a hit
well you do and you still don't have
what I have you feel me like that [__]
don't be making sense and adding up it's
ego it's ego it's because they can't do
it so they go resort to that I had
someone I was talking to um someone from
a label and I I was telling him like
we're about to scale to this next level
he was like man I think if you just kind
of um if you if you work on the music
Side Y yada and I was just like do you
hear the [__] that's blowing up there's
not one artist right now who can make a
do that little dance a family business
some of these songs I've made is like
[__] do you hear what we talk there's
no rap artist who's doing what the [__]
I'm doing and you [__] talking about
some music to me with all the stupid
[__] we hear blowing up it's like y'all
in y'all are insane and the whole
industry is like delusional and Faking
It these [__] don't like these songs
that's being pushed and that's on the
radio and that's getting exposed no they
don't listen to them in their car they
don't listen to them at home you feel me
but everybody's rallying behind this
[__] and acting like we we we really
it's just weird and everyone has a
job right and that's what I've learned
all of the people we're talking about
are employed exactly and and it is in
their best interest to keep their
employment status J push whatever comes
across my autonomy this long like bro
was just saying before he walked out he
like man you've been holding out and
it's like I haven't even been holding
out I'm just
unimpressed that's fair fair I mean I I
do appreciate the transparency that
you've provided to a lot of artists
because you brought up that Rock Nation
meeting that you had and I had had
similar meeting with with Rock Nation
didn't get it quite as far as you but um
with my artist and then I've heard two
or three other people say similar [__]
and but people don't know you could just
take the name Rock Nation out of it
because I got homies over there any
label that's the conversation that's
happening yeah it is the terms are
always against you like for the man it's
very tough it's very tough to I've yet
to get a deal from a major that made me
feel great I've yet to get an offer from
a how many offers have you gotten if you
had to you know throw a number out north
of north of 15 north of 10 for sure I'd
say about 10 seven to 10 I mean that's
that's about all of them
right yeah it's man and they're they're
never impressive they're never
impressive it's like um I don't know
they just don't get it they they lack
the ability to understand what's coming
and what's next or what's happening and
I'm someone who
um they got terms in a contract like man
the last contract we got we was all in
the airport and we was reading through
it and I was putting like te and splash
on gang this is what this mean this is
what this mean and it's a lot of [__] in
the contract that's like for a
developing artist and [__] and it's like
y'all don't even take the time and a due
diligence to make a contract based on
who you're doing business with yeah like
you guys didn't even like this is a
standard deal that you're going to offer
10 other people at the very least let me
read something in here that makes you
think like oh they're they're offering L
Russell a deal bro I had a deal that
wanted to take um I think it was 16 or
18% of my entertainment income and I was
and what does that mean like how do they
even Define that all money's from
entertainment so so
all money from entertainment which is
which is crazy not live show entertain
more so it's like if you end up doing
like a war T yeah right ENT anything you
make in an entertainment and it's like
I've been making money in entertainment
way before [__] didn't offered me a
deal so it's like to come and tell
someone you want a percent of that is
just like
unjustifiable for what what you intend
to provide like I've already broken
myself as an artist and this next year
going to go even crazier I've been
cracking more codes where it's like oh
[__] it's up there's even deals um
where labels will want a piece of if you
start a clothing line while you're
signed yep that they can somehow figure
out was from the music they want a piece
of it this this just happened to a
friend of mine who my boy's got a really
big clothing line I mean it's huge he
had signed a deal probably 2012
2013 and there was actually a discussion
that he might have to give up some of
his clothing line yeah and I understand
some of the terms for um an artist that
you take from nothing who like no one
knows this [__] and all of a sudden
everyone those people AR getting deals
though I under they're getting three
they are are they they just getting
three they're getting it it's a all
encompassing deal because they're making
they're making your brand but to take a
[__] who's coming in who's already
selling out shows and selling tickets
and selling Stu and say oh we want this
it's just like you're [__]
insane you don't even have an artist on
your roster that's at the level that I'm
at but you want those things so there
are situations in which you could see a
360 deal benefi an artist I think a 360
deal is hyper beneficial if you're a
businessman like if you cuz every artist
don't have streaming but some of us I
did half a million on my own shows last
year not counting outside performances I
do half a million on merch so if you're
able to leverage those things in
exchange for Capital outside of the
Stream man I don't think that's a bad
deal I think that's a great if you go
partner with anyone and you say hey I
love your business I want a percent I'll
put all this money up that's not a bad
thing that's what every [__] startup
company tech company does it's I think
it's a bad thing when it's
like when you don't give a [__] the
amount of funds to actually build it or
the infrastructure and resource actually
build it and you're just going to take
it it's a little it's different it's a
little more a little ping or if you if
if it's someone who's already
established all this [__] and you're not
giving them the means of capital to
excel it but you want to take it it's
just like bro you got to contribute to
get out of that [__] I heard uh did you
ever see the leor Cohen interview he
explained the 360 deal yeah so he kind
of explained it as if you and I start a
restaurant together and I'm the investor
and and you start taking the sauce
that's popping and selling it at Walmart
do I get a piece of the sauce and I I
understood it from that angle and like
you said like if you're an artist who
doesn't have a cult following doesn't
have a brand doesn't really have
anything going maybe a little Tik Tok
moment maybe it is worth it it makes so
much sense in the machine you'll get on
the other side of that deal
eventually and they it'll help you
recoup faster MH it'll help cuz product
sells way faster than music right so
you'll be able to recoup and be out your
situation way faster if it aligns like I
said if someone's helping you build all
those revenues like if if you don't have
a merch business going and someone says
oh I I'll help you make a million
dollars in merch yeah I think they
should have a percent yeah if you to do
that [__] standard for every [__] that
comes in this office you just offer it
to him it's like like some of my issues
with some of the deals I got is like
I'll give a proposal and they ask what I
want and I'll get the contract back and
it's a bunch of [__] that we didn't even
discuss it's like you don't you don't
just throw something in a [__] contract
without it's like a political Bill like
they be likeo they be trying to throw so
much [__] into these bills that are
supposed to be about something else and
you like really reading like wait what
we're fun what